la parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame dominique estrosi sassone pour
les républicains avaient la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
vous demander de bien vouloir excuser
notre président du groupe
le président bruno retailleau qui
malheureusement ne peut être parmi nous
ce matin il est retenu dans son
département aux sables d'olonne pour
l'hommage national aux sauveteurs de la
snsm qui ont péris en mer vendredi
dernier
[Applaudissements]
nous sortons d'une séquence électorale
intense
les uns en sortent satisfaits d'autres
un peu moi un peu moins beaucoup encore
moins pour autant monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
comptons bien continuer à défendre nos
convictions sereinement mais fermement
sereinement car la politique ce n'est
pas la guerre nous ne voyons sur les
bancs du gouvernement
aucun ennemi nous nous désolons même d'y
voir siéger
certains de nos âmes ce que vous tendiez
la main au maire c'est votre droit que
quelques-uns la saisisse c'est leur
choix mais que certains tape sur les
doigts de ceux qui auraient l'impudence
de ne pas faire de même
cela est inacceptable
[Applaudissements]
les élus locaux ne sont les obligés de
personnes les seuls devant lesquels ils
doivent répondre ce n'est ni vous ni
nous ce sont leurs administrés et
puisque la constitution nous a donné
pour mission de les représenter de
défendre leur liberté
nous vous disons monsieur le premier
ministre ne cédez pas de nouveau à la
tentation de la toute puissance qui
attend abîmé le lien de confiance avec
les élus locaux du reste et je le dis là
encore avec beaucoup de sérénité
nous n'acceptons pas cette affirmation
selon laquelle l'intérêt du pays nous
serait étranger depuis deux ans le
groupe auquel nous appartenons a
toujours refusé l'obstruction un très
intransigeante au profit de l'opposition
intelligente nous sommes nous opposer
aux ordonnances du travail non nous les
avons voté parce que nous estimons que
même si elles étaient insuffisantes
elle allait dans le bon sens avons-nous
tenter de faire échouer la réforme de la
sncf
non nous ne vous avons appuyé parce que
nous considérions que compte tenu des
carences de notre système ferroviaire
décor pozzobon corporatisme que depuis
trop longtemps le fragilise l'exigence
de réformes devaient primer de même
avant nous repousser la loi est lent ou
celle sur les mobilités ses textes
loin de les rejeter nous les avons
amélioré parce que notre mission de
législateurs prime sur toute autre
considération parce que nous sommes au
sénat bien moins perméable aux patients
et aux agitations qui parfois domine à
l'assemblée nationale et je pourrais
également évoqué les mesures d'urgence
décidées par le président de la
république au pic de la crise de l'hiver
dernier des mesures que nous avons voté
parce que nous considérions que compte
tenu de l'état de tension dans le pays
il fallait collectivement répondre à
l'urgence et mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que l'ordre et la sérénité revienne
nous n'avons jamais été dans une
opposition pavlovienne notre position
est claire et je crois que les scènes
sur le plan démocratique quand nous
estimons qu'un texte est bon pour le
pays
nous le votons quand il nous paraît
qu'il ne l'est pas
nous ne votons pas car s'il peut y avoir
avec vous des convergences et nous en
avons trouvé
monsieur le premier ministre dans votre
discours la fin des régimes spéciaux de
retraite la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou le débat annuel au parlement
sur l'immigration mais il ya aussi de
vraies différences non pas des
différences de forme mais les
différences de fond lorsque vous allez
lancer des milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires sans indiquer comment
vous les financerait sinon en rabotant
ici ou là quelques niches fiscales
au lieu de présenter aux français un
véritable plan d'économies au risque de
faire porter sur les générations futures
la charge financière de vos décisions
c'est une différence de fond lorsque
vous refusez d'indexer les aides
accordées aux familles et que vous
poursuivez l'entreprise de fragilisation
de la politique familiale engagées par
françois hollande c'est une différence
de fond lorsque vous engager notre
protection sociale vers un système de
moins en moins universel c'est une
différence de fond lorsque la production
la protection de l'environnement se
traduit par une fiscalité punitive
c'est une différence de fond ces
différentes nous ne la revendiquons pas
seulement pour nous mêmes mais aussi
pour défendre ce qui nous engage tous la
crédibilité de la parole publique
tout d'abord car l'honneur de la
politique c'est de défendre des
convictions sans céder à l'esprit du
temps ou à l'opportunité du moment
l'efficacité dans la conduite des
affaires du pays
car aucun gouvernement aucune majorité
aucun pouvoir ne dispose de la vérité
absolue
j'en veux pour preuve la loi
anti-casseurs c'était comme vous le
savez une proposition notre groupe
porté par bruno retailleau vous l'avait
initialement écarté pour ensuite la
reprendre à votre compte
face aux violences urbaines auxquelles
vous avez été confrontés et nous nous en
félicitons aussi nous sommes en droit
d'attendre que le gouvernement et la
même attitude constructive dont a fait
preuve le sénat et vous avez monsieur le
premier ministre
une nouvelle occasion de bénéficier de
la sagesse des sénateurs avec le projet
de réforme institutionnelle
oui une réforme est nécessaire pour
revitaliser la démocratie français
tant au plan national que local pour ré
articuler la démocratie représentative
avec la démocratie directe et
participative oui une révision
constitutionnelle est possible elle est
possible si le gouvernement fait preuve
de cette ouverture que vous mettez
pourtant en avant autant nous saluons
votre décision d'avoir renoncé à
certaines atteintes au parlement autant
nous déplorons que sur la question de la
représentation des territoires et donc
des dans celle du nombre de
parlementaires vous sembliez privilégier
le rapport de force voire la pression
pour nous qui portons la voix des
territoires
ce point n'est pas secondaire il est
majeur car il touche à la justice
territoriale
il est juste que tous les territoires
soient représentés il est juste qu'il
n'y ait pas plus de 20 départements ne
disposant que d'un sénateur et que cette
garantie fasse l'objet d'une disposition
constitutionnelle
autrement dit c'est en partant de
l'exigence d'équité et de
représentativité territoriale que le
nombre de sénateurs doit être fixée à
bas et non pas à partir d'une logique
arithmétique
sinon technocratique n'ajoutons pas au
fracture géographique une déchirure
démocratique en éloignant encore un peu
plus la république des territoires dans
bien des communes rurales ou des villes
moyennes le sentiment d'abandon domine
la conviction qu'on ne compte pour rien
et largement partagée
elle fut d'ailleurs au coeur de cette
crise des idées gilet jaune que vous
avez dû affronter alors tirer tous les
enseignements de cette crise n'accentue
et pas cette désespérance en supprimant
après les services publics
le service démocratique cas sur les
parlementaires du reste cela fait un an
que nous avons exprimé nos exigences
préalables à toute révision
constitutionnelle qu'attendez vous pour
nous dire oui ou non au delà de cette
question majeure
nous souhaitons vous le savez renouer
avec l'esprit initial de la vème
république
je pense évidemment au respect du
bicamérisme au renouvellement par moitié
du sénat
notamment pour assurer le principe de la
continuité des pouvoirs publics
enfin ces différences que nous assumons
sont aussi nous le croyons un gage de
concorde et d'unité certains dans votre
majorité ont exprimé leur satisfaction
au lendemain des élections européennes
pourtant la réalité géographique et
civiques que dessine ces chiffres n'a
rien de satisfaisante mais exprime au
contraire une situation dont nul ne peut
se féliciter
celle d'un pays fracturé de deux france
profondément opposé vous vouliez
dépasser les vieux clivages
mais vous n'êtes pas venu qu'à leur
substituer des clivages autrement plus
dangereux des clivages territoriaux des
clivages sociaux des clivages culturelle
et générationnelle même des clivages qui
en réalité épousent les lignes de cette
recomposition que vous poursuivez la
poutre travaille encore disiez vous
monsieur le premier ministre
prenez garde qu'à force de travail et
elle ne fracturé les murs porteurs de
l'édifice français prenez garde que dans
ceux nous et eux que vous avez installé
face au rassemblement national la
perspective d'une réconciliation de tous
les français ne s'effondre prise entre
des forces irréconciliables bien sûr les
fossés qui se creusent entre nos
concitoyens ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
mais c'est à vous qu'il revient de les
combler
plutôt que de les creuser car le grand
défi que nous allons devoir relever dans
les années qui viennent
celui qui vous incombe aujourd'hui
d'affronter c'est celui de l'unité cette
grande oeuvre française toujours à
recommencer cette unité ne pourra se
faire que dans la vérité parce que
toujours le mensonge divise les
illusions sépare
regardons les choses en face les deux me
vérité et les vrais mensonges n'ont fait
qu'accentuer la méfiance des français
ils ont conduit les uns à rechercher des
boucs émissaires
pousser les autres à s'enfermer dans
leur vérité a abandonné la raison
critique pour les raisonnements
irrationnel pour recréer les conditions
de l'amitié civique
il faut avoir le courage de dire dire la
vérité sur l'état de nos finances
publiques sur la situation de nos
comptes sociaux qui de nouveau plongent
dans le rouge sur l'impossibilité de se
tenir
artificiellement la croissance et le
pouvoir d'achat
entre-temps indéfiniment les déficits
dire la vérité sur le chômage les
paramètres actuels qu'il s'agisse de
dépenses publiques et des déficits ne
permettront pas d'atteindre l'objectif
de 7% de choses de chômage d'ici la fin
du quinquennat
la conjoncture ne suffit plus à créer
l'embellie dire la vérité sur l'état de
prostitution scolaire sur la nécessité
d'étoffer la diversité des parcours de
donner plus de liberté pour recruter
pour innover mais de renouer aussi avec
la transmission
celle qui permet d'échapper à la
reproduction sociale et surtout de
réaffirmer la valeur du mérite et du
travail en vous éloignant de la
tentation de la discrimination positive
dire la vérité sur l'immigration
également qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
régulé sur le communautarisme ou les
atteintes à la laïcité qui trop souvent
ne sont pas encore sanctionné dire la
vérité en somme surtout ses non dits sur
ces dénis qui ont frayé la voie aux
extrêmes partout dans les démocraties
occidentales
le sentiment d'insécurité culturel
progresse des questionnements
fondamentaux se font entendre sur la
nation sur les frontières sur le rapport
à la mondialisation ne pas offrir des
réponses démocratique à ses
interrogations légitimes rester
insensible aux angoisses et au sentiment
de dépossession qu'exprime bon nombre de
nos compatriotes s'est exposé la
république à des insurrections
électorale c'est nous exposer
collectivement aux aventures sans
lendemain dans lesquelles nous
entraînerait les extrêmes
si par malheur elle parvenait aux
responsabilités
cette unité ne la feront que dans le
cadre d'un débat apaisé respectueux de
chacun sait sont les caractères les
caricatures les anathèmes manichéen
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
indiqué ne pas vous résigner au
rétrécissement du débat public
mais enfin qui depuis deux ans rétrécir
le débat a déposé des oppositions
binaires sans nuances qui n'a cessé de
dire qu'il n'y avait désormais les
progressistes d'un côté et les
conservateurs de l'autre les
représentants du monde d'avant et les
héros du monde nouveau ce n'est pas le
sénat c'est le président de la
république c'est votre gouvernement nous
nous vous le disons calmement mais
franchement le progrès n'est pas une
marque déposée par la majorité
nous voulons tous le progrès accepter
seulement que nous puissions en avoir
une vision parfois différente de celle
que vous nourrissez et y aient
l'humilité de reconnaître que la
modernité n'est pas univoque que ce qui
est ancien n'est pas forcément datée est
dépassé c'est l'exemple d'ailleurs de
l'institution communale elle est sans
nul doute l'une des plus anciennes et
c'est d'abord à elle que nos
compatriotes accordent leur confiance
c'est d'ailleurs vers l vers les mers
que vous vous êtes immédiatement tourné
l'hiver dernier lorsque la situation
s'est enflammé après les avoir pourtant
tant méprisé les maires n'ont jamais été
autant décourager et vous devez tenir
compte de leur découragement
du reste nous pensons qu'à l'heure des
grandes ruptures et des changements
permanents
la politique doit être aussi un facteur
de stabilité s'il est essentiel de
changer ce qu'il faut il est tout autant
de préserver ce qui vaut de protéger ses
attachements vitaux qui nous tiennent
comme un seul peuple une seule nation
c'est aussi le message qu'on envoyait
beaucoup d'électeurs lors de ce scrutin
européen
non les français ne sont pas des gaulois
réfractaires au changement mais ils
tiennent à leur souveraineté
ils tiennent à leur laïcité ils tiennent
à leur solidarité nationale car ses
attachements sont autant d'appui
nécessaire pour que nous puissions
prendre collectivement notre élan
nous projeter et nous imposer dans un
monde nouveau qui a besoin de la france
prenons le meilleur de la modernité et
donnant le meilleur de notre identité
voilà en même temps qu'ils pour le cours
pourrait rassembler une majorité de
français monsieur le premier ministre
c'est dans cet esprit d'unité que nous
voulons continuer d'oeuvrer l'unité
n'est pas pour nous synonyme
d'uniformité dans une démocratie adulte
la pluralité doit être vécue comme une
richesse et non comme un obstacle
nous avons des différences et nous
aurons encore peut-être des convergences
et c'est au nom de ces différences que
nous assumons et de ces convergences que
nous espérons que dans le cadre du vote
que vous nous demandez le groupe l'est
républicain s'abstiendra majoritairement
et cela pour deux raisons essentielles
d'abord parce que le sénat n'est pas
l'assemblée nationale il n'est ni dans
ses attributions ni dans ses missions de
renverser ou non tel ou tel gouvernement
ensuite parce que depuis deux ans nous
avons été trop habitués à ce décalage
entre d'un côté des mots forts et de
l'autre des actes faible autrement dit
cette abstention c'est tout sauf un
chèque en blanc
nous jugerons sur pièce au cas par cas
texte par texte ni opposition
systématique ni adhésion automatique
telle est notre ligne de conduite cette
ligne nous la tiendrons monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres nous le tiendrons parce
que au-delà de nos appartenances
il y à la france nous le tiendrons parce
que nous tenons à nos convictions parce
que nous croyons à ce que nous défendons
l'oeil
[Applaudissements]